[Applaudissements]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public 90 minutes
de débat et de reportage pour donner du
sens à l'actualité grâce à nos experts
et voici le sommaire de ce 14 décembre
l'actu pour commencer et l'Europe qui
adopte une taxe carbone assez frontières
pour verdir ses importations c'était une
mesure attendue depuis longtemps mais
certains industriels français la jugent
trop compliqué elle est pourtant censée
les protéger d'une concurrence déloyale
explication et confrontation d'idées
dans une minute et puis pour notre débat
de société c'est l'histoire d'une
ambition que l'on vous raconte le train
la SNCF le TGV la France peut-elle
encore sans leur vieillir de sa
politique ferroviaire Emmanuel Macron en
est convaincu
et donc nous avons ainsi réengagé une
politique d'investissement relancer le
train de nuit et lancer en février 2020
le fameux plan petite ligne tout ce qui
a été mis en oeuvre depuis 4 ans a
permis
de protéger parfois de réparer de
commencer à réenvisager l'avenir
pourtant sur ces lignes intercitées
souvent les régions disent leur
ras-le-bol de supplay les
investissements manquants de l'État on
va débattre de l'avenir du rail français
en jeu majeur de notre transition
écologique dans 45 minutes mais d'abord
cet accord européen sur la taxe carbone
présentée comme historique et détaillé
par Jonathan Dupriez
c'est l'une des mesures phares pour
accélérer la décarbonation de
l'industrie sur le Vieux Continent
l'Union européenne vient d'adopter une
taxe carbone aux frontières ce
dispositif unique au monde permettra de
taxer les importations de marchandises
provenant de pays tiers au normes
environnementales moins strictes que
lieu et ce dans 6 secteurs l'acier le
ciment l’engrais et l'électricité ou
encore l'hydrogène grâce à ce dispositif
l'Union européenne pensait éviter le
dumping écologique qui verrait les
industriels délocaliser leurs production
hors de l'Europe tout en encourageant le
reste du monde accroître son ambition
climatique cette avancée a été saluée
par le Président de la République sur
Twitter pour le climat en européen nous
ne cessons d'agir l'Union européenne a
adopté une taxe carbone aux frontières
notre exigence de réduction des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre 26
s'imposer aux produits que nous
importons on avance mais cette taxe
carbone aux frontières suscite des
industriels des secteurs concernés si
les importations coûtent plus cher leur
coûts de production risque mécaniquement
d'augmenter en résulterait des produits
plus chers pour le consommateur et donc
une baisse de leur compétitivité au lieu
d'aider à la réindustrialisation de
l'Europe cette taxe vient entraver la
compétitivité de nos industries
européennes pourtant au cœur des enjeux
de la transition écologique les
industriels ont encore du temps devant
eux la complexité du mécanisme pousse
l'Union européenne à le mettre
progressivement en oeuvre pour une
effectivité en 2026 ou 2027 comme le
souligne l'euro député Pascal
camphinides on aura besoin de trois ans
pour mettre en place la taxe carbone aux
frontières parce que nous n'avons pas
encore de système informatique pour la
gérer pas encore de procédure dédiées
pour l'importation et l'exportation
depuis les pays tiers et j'en passe donc
sachant que nous sommes les premiers au
monde à faire cela il nous faudra ces
trois années
[Musique]
parce que ce sont des secteurs tout
simplement très émissive de gaz à effet
de serre par contre je pense qu'il y a
une chose qui est très importante
d'expliquer pour les gens qui nous
écoutent c'est que la mise en place de
ce mécanisme d'ajustement carbone aux
frontières s'accompagne de la politique
des quotas carbone de l'Union européenne
c'est à dire que pourquoi on met la taxe
carbone aux frontières c'est pour
rééquilibrer aussi les mécanismes qu'on
est en train de mettre en place et qu'on
va appliquer à nos propres industries
sur le territoire européen et on
expliquera en détails
mais parce qu'il y a aussi quelque chose
qui se passe sur le territoire européen
pour compléter la politique carbone
européenne et donc pourquoi ces secteurs
parce qu'ils sont très émetteurs de gaz
à effet de serre notamment parce que
certains sont électro intensifs d'accord
Anne-Sophie elle est-ce que les géants
de ces secteurs ils ne sont pas
européens ou alors est-ce qu'ils ne
produisent plus en Europe si on essaye
d'aller un peu plus loin dans la logique
alors il y a plusieurs choses déjà ce
sont des secteurs en effet l'acier
l'aluminium qu'avaient déjà été sur le
devant de la scène
je m'en souviens pas mais lorsque la
Chine a adhéré à l'Organisation mondiale
du commerce 15 ans après elle devait
avoir accès au statut d'économie de
marché et la conséquence de ça notamment
sur l'acier et l'aluminium c'était en
effet l'arrivée de ces produits à des
coûts très bas et donc il vous aviez des
milliers d'emplois en Europe qui étaient
menacés l'Europe par rapport à ça à
refaire un règlement avec les États-Unis
c'était contre l'octroi de ce statut
pour justement protéger donc on voit
bien que derrière ça il y a quand même
aussi l'idée d'un protectionnisme sur
des secteurs qui sont très intensifs en
énergie et aussi ce qu'il faut regarder
c'est ces secteurs alors beaucoup et
produits à l'étranger notamment en Chine
en Asie viennent sur le marché européen
mais ce sont aussi des secteurs où les
chaînes de valeur sont très très
disparaître et très éclatées ce sont des
secteurs qui ont énormément d'étapes de
production à l'étranger or Union
européenne donc dès que vous avez des
mesures protectionnistes chinoises ou
américaines ce sont des secteurs qui
tout de suite et bien en pâtissent et
donc vous avez un une augmentation de
coûts et une perte de compétitivité de
l'Europe notamment par rapport au pays
tiers pour pas la nommer l'Asie donc là
concrètement c'est en termes d'emploi
une protection parce que c'est des
secteurs qu'on me l'a dit qui sont très
énergivores et puis l'autre c'est aussi
de dire de tracer pendant ces trois ans
il y aura ça c'est un peu ce qu'a fait
Lyra aux États-Unis
donc c'est un partenariat qui a été mis
en place par le président Biden qui est
censé lutter contre l'inflation mais qui
va tracer les produits industriels donc
notamment en Chine réduction
et donc l'idée c'est de tracer aussi
d'où viennent ces produits et s'ils sont
chinois d'avoir en effet des taxes en
tout cas d'avoir des entraves au marché
donc on voit que sur ces secteurs qui
sont très internationalisés l'Europe et
c'est aussi de mettre le même domaine
donc c'est pas que écologique il y a
aussi un aspect commercial très
important et alors vous l'avez un peu
évoqué mais Dimitri Carbonel on voit ces
secteurs ils sont cruciaux pour notre
économie on va pas pouvoir s'en passer
est-ce que ça veut dire qu'il y aura
forcément des hausses de prix aussi pour
les consommateurs alors tout d'abord
c'est un certain nombre de secteur
particuliers qui sont en général on va
pas acheter des tonnes d'acier mais
effectivement ça va des répercussions
sur
c'est pas le consommateur qui achète
l'acier mais ça va avoir des
répercussions effectivement
potentiellement sur les industries après
il comme un point particulier c'est à
dire que si par exemple on construit
imaginons je sais pas au Maroc ou
ailleurs et qu'on importe donc son acier
d'un pays qui n'est pas soumis à cet axe
à ce moment-là
à l'heure actuelle effectivement on va
pouvoir réexporter en Europe sans avoir
effectivement ces taxes toutefois il y a
un mécanisme sur le plan européen qui
intègre cette dimension là donc
effectivement il y a potentiellement un
risque d'augmentation des prix toutefois
comme de l'autre côté il y a comme enfin
je sais pas si le mot taxe c'est exact
mais en tout cas il y a un certain
nombre de fonds qui vont revenir sur le
port européen est-ce qu'ensuite ce sera
redistribuer derrière sur un certain
nombre de ces industries c'est peut-être
une un moyen justement de réduire ça
alors il faut peut-être expliquer ça à
nettoyer c'est plus le produit est
transformé plus que ça se complique
c'est pour ça qu'on dit certains ont dit
c'est une usine à gaz cet accord rentrer
dans le détail
et voir par le ciment d'acier donc on
parle de
matière il va falloir voir s'il
s'applique sur des produits semi-finis
ou finis parce que dans le cas où il ne
s'appliquerait pas sur les produits
semi-finis qui était la première lecture
qu'on avait et moi j'attends d'avoir le
détail technique qu'on comme je n'ai pas
encore eu et bien ça risque plutôt
justement d'être contre-productif
c'est-à-dire qu'on va faire rentrer sur
le territoire européen des produits
légèrement transformés pour contourner
l'attaque et donc ça va se faire au
détriment de nos producteurs européens
et là dans l'absolu la crainte compte
beaucoup d'industriels en dehors du fait
que ça va être compliqué à mettre en
oeuvre c'est que finalement je fais
venir une automobile qui est produite en
Chine et bien ne sera peut-être pas
soumise à ce mécanisme d'ajustement
carbone frontières
chinois dans cette chinois mais alors
c'est comment vous allez le détailler
comment vous allez intégrer la chaîne de
valeur savoir où ont lieu les
différentes étapes de transformation
vous regardez à un contenu carbone mais
il y a aussi une question qu'on peut se
poser est-ce qu'aujourd'hui le contenu
carbone d'une production dans certains
pays européens et tel moins 10 ans sur
le plan environnemental que le contenu
carbone en Asie donc c'est toutes ces
questions qu'il faut poser et démêler
c'est-à-dire si vous êtes d'un point de
vue français vous avez un mix
énergétique qui est globalement moins
carbonée que vous ne pouvez la voir en
Allemagne ou en Pologne vous en
réjouissez mais si vous êtes en Pologne
ou en Allemagne vous avez un contenu
énergétique qui est mix énergétique qui
est beaucoup plus carbonée alors la
question se pose et toutes ces
explications en fait tout se détaille
technique c'est les explications qu'on
attend pour voir si ça aide vraiment un
moteur de réindustrialisation ou plutôt
un facteur de destruction d'activités
industrielles sur le territoire européen
tous les inquiétudes exprimés
effectivement par certains industriels
je rappelle le calendrier octobre 2023
les importateurs devront déclarer la
quantité d'émission contenu dans les
biens reçus et 2026 2027 entrée en
viewer de la taxe carbone en écoutait
Anne-Sophie elle siffle tout à l'heure
Pascal Campin nous dire qu'il y avait
pas encore le système informatique pour
se lancer ça nous a fait un peu sourire
et en même temps c'est pas très
rassurant quand on se ça va être si
compliqué que ça alors c'est sûr que ça
va être compliqué parce qu'il va avoir
cette question de traçabilité c'est vrai
que des fois on pourrait se dire mais là
à ce moment là on est vraiment dans un
protectionnisme offensif et on désigne
des des pays qu'on dit ne pas respecter
les normes quel que soit on va dire leur
les produits exportés c'est ce que c'est
très bien fait les États-Unis avec les
batteries en disant voilà c'est les
batteries sont un temps elles viennent
de temps de la Chine il y aura il y aura
pas d'aide donc là c'est vrai que c'est
excessivement clair mais là ça en effet
très offensif et ce sera très difficile
au niveau européen je pense avoir un
consensus là-dessus donc c'est vrai que
comme l'idée encore une fois c'est on
est pour réduire les émissions et ce
n'est pas forcément du protectionnisme
et bien en effet c'est vrai que le focus
est fait sur le X énergétique mais là en
effet pour voir dans la chaîne de valeur
où a été produit tel ou tel gaz etc
c'est sûr que ça va être très compliqué
Dimitri oui il y a il y a un point qui
est important c'est que si par exemple
un constructeur automobile
achète son acier en Europe et que il
trouve un acier qui est équivalent avec
la même émission de carbone qui sont
faites par exemple au Japon ou ailleurs
peu importe évidemment il a pas plus
enfin il y aura pas de taxes
additionnelles ou même je reprends un
exemple
japonais qui produit en dessous d'un
certain seuil donc limite qui est fixée
au niveau européen ne paiera pas
justement donc ces pays-là à être mieux
10 ans en termes d'émission carbone
c'est ce que vous nous dites
effectivement après il y a un autre
point concernant la traçabilité il y a
quand même un mécanisme de entre
guillemets par défaut si et ça peut être
d’ailleurs un moyen entre guillemets de
d'avoir des informations c'est si
comment dire on est comment dire si le
producteur va au dessus d'un
respectivement d'un certain seuil on va
par défaut on va lui donner une sorte de
émission de CO2 qui va être important et
il y a potentiellement pas à justifier
en dessous si là en dessous d'un certain
seuil là il aura peut-être c'est
effectivement des éléments à donner pour
justifier qu'il paye moins que vous
écoutez on se dit que c'est
effectivement compliqué on attend
d'avoir le détail mais que oui ben voilà
c'est ce que je les ai sur Matthieu j'ai
juste une question de basique cette taxe
carbone elle concerne la production elle
concerne pas les coûts de transport
parce qu'un acier chinois peut être
produit dans des conditions
environnementales
enfin pour imaginer que ce soit correct
mais rien que le fait de le trimballer
jusqu'en Europe alors est-ce que il y a
un bilan carbone qui est ma connaissance
non mais encore une fois il faut
connaître le détail mais pour moi c'est
pas c'est pas inclus dans le périmètre
on est vraiment sur la la production et
non pas le l'impact des transports
encore encore une fois il faut bien être
vigilant c'est à dire que on le présente
comme c'est bien de préciser que c'est
pas une mesure protectionniste parce que
ça s'accompagne d'un effort sur notre
marché c'est à dire que il va y avoir
des quotas carbone sur le marché
européen donc c'est pas quelque chose
qui va permettre de lutter contre un
dumping social ou un dumping fiscal
c'est vraiment sur une question de tenir
la trajectoire carbone et ambition
carbone des pays membres de l'Union
européenne
Mathieu on va on va évoluer le caractère
on va dire historique de cette mesure
avant je vous propose de voir la
réaction sur Twitter de Christophe Bich
je suis ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires cette nuit les États membres
de l'Union européenne se sont accordés
sur une taxe carbone aux frontières pour
verdir les importations industrielles un
accord historique pour le climat pour
vous c'est d'abord le signe d'une de la
fin d'une forme de naïveté européenne et
d'une expression célèbre oui parce que
je dis que son sonne peut-être
aujourd'hui la fin d'une expression qui
a fait Flores dans le débat politique
depuis plusieurs années et qui faisait
de l'Europe l'idiot du village mondial
ou l'idiot du village global alors la
paternité de la formule elle revient à
l'ancien ministre des Affaires
étrangères Hubert Védrines mais le
fusain abondamment repris après lui à
droite à gauche on se souvient même de
façon officielle on se viendralement de
Bourg alors ministre du redressement
productif et pas hésité à tancer à
Bruxelles les commissaires européens et
puis ces homologues en reprenant cette
expression pour que l'Union européenne
protège à l'époque son industrie
automobile ce qui était risqué pas
rencontré un très très grand succès
alors si on rentre un peu dans le détail
qu'est-ce qu'elle voulait dire cette
expression mais en gros que l'Europe
c'est chiner jusqu'à présent inventé ou
à respecter des règles dont ses
concurrents comme la Chine ou les
États-Unis ne s'embarrassent guère en
bon élève de l'Organisation mondiale du
commerce et puis sous influence quand
même assez libérales elle a ouvert et
libéralisé ces marchés elle a cassé ses
monopoles au nom de la fameuse
concurrence libre et non fossé ou sonner
de ce petit refrain qu'on entendait
beaucoup mais en sacrifiant parfois des
pas entier de son industrie en empêchant
l'émergence parfois de champion
nationaux ou en fragilisant encore ces
entreprises publiques et ce alors même
que ces rivaux multipliés de leur côté
des barrières protectionnistes que ce
soit par le biais capitalistique ou
bureaucratique je pense à la Chine par
exemple que ce soit par le biais de
subventions déguisés plus ou moins
déguisés et là je pense aux États-Unis
or ça fait des années quand même que les
grands leaders européens nous promettent
une Europe ouverte et non offerte tiens
voilà une autre expression c'était
Jacques Delors celle-ci à la terre aussi
reprise abondamment je me souviens de
Jean-Claude Juncker qui la reprenait des
années que des voix s'élèvent pour
appeler les Européens à se protéger
ensemble plutôt que de se tirer la
bourre en gros les uns les autres et des
années que par tropisme lib ou par souci
de jouer la carte nationale ou voir
incapacité à se mettre d'accord entre
eux ces projets capotés ça fait quand
même 20 ans qu'on en parle est-ce
qu'elle peut est-ce qu'elle va changer
la donne mais elle est pas exemple de
critiques sans doute et on va en parler
pendant cette émission on peut regretter
que l'Union européenne est choisi de
taxer plutôt que de subventionner comme
font les États-Unis on peut regretter
douter de sa faisabilité ou regretter
encore qu'elle s'applique voilà vous
avez bien expliqué c'est en fait pour
pas qu'il y ait un défaut de concurrence
pour le coup entre les entreprises
européennes qui sont soumises à des
normes particulières qu'on fait cette
taxe carbone pour les entreprises
étrangères à l'Union mais enfin le fait
que les 27 soit parvenus à se mettre
d'accord en écoutant notamment de la
voix de la France qu'on avait fait un
cheval de bataille Marc à mes yeux un
vrai tournant et montre que si l'Europe
a encore des progrès à faire pour gagner
la bataille économique là en tout cas
commencer à s'armer ou à se réarmer et
en gros il est jamais trop tard pour
bien faire Anne-Sophie a aussi fait ce
que vous vous y voyez effectivement une
la fin d'une forme de naïveté européenne
oui complétant mais c'est vrai que c'est
souvent en termes de crise et moi ce que
je déplore c'est que souvent on réagit
par rapport à ce que font les autres
quand j'ai parlé de la loctrode de
statut d'économie de marché et qu'on a
fait tout d'un coup ce règlement très
rapidement très efficace là ça a été
excessivement efficace en effet on a les
moyens de le faire donc en tant que crie
c'est vrai que l'Europe est très
efficace la difficulté c'est pourquoi
être en temps de crise et arriver jusque
là ce serait bien d'anticiper tout ça
surtout que encore une fois le
protectionnisme et ses mesures là donc
de tarifs de douane de d'obstacles en
tarifaire ça fait 15 ans que c'est norme
ne cesse augmenter pas seulement aux
États-Unis en Chine mais en Russie en
Inde en Amérique du Sud donc absolument
partout ça va continuer donc maintenant
qu'on a conscience de ça plutôt que de
toujours réagir par rapport aux autres
essayons d'anticiper ensemble pour
justement pouvoir préserver l'industrie
et c'est vrai que là l'objectif alors
c'est la réduction des émissions les
États-Unis c'est la lutte contre
l'inflation mais il faut là aussi pas
être dupe derrière il y a aussi quand
même la guerre de la technologie qui se
qui se fait et l'idée c'est quand même
essayer de l'avoir sur son territoire
sur son sol donc là aussi il faut
vraiment avoir une vision à mon sens de
moyen long terme et non pas juste être
sur un élément bien sûr il faut
réindustrialiser il faut se décarboner
mais c'est un tout et très souvent en
fait c'est vrai que ces mesures font le
focus sur un aspect inflation des
carbonisations mais il y a pas de de ce
que vous dites c'est que il y a il y a
l'enjeu qu'on est en train de vivre de
la transformation
environnementale pour la réussir il y
aura besoin de d'innovation de rupture
c'est ça et en ce moment les grands
espaces économiques se font la
concurrence pour attirer les meilleurs
c'est ce qui est en train de se passer
c'est ça ce qui est en train de se
passer donc là on dit voilà il va avoir
des entreprises qui vont aux Etats-Unis
parce que l'énergie est cinq fois moins
cher ce qui est le cas mais derrière ça
c'est vrai à court terme derrière le but
des États-Unis c'est que cette
technologie reste et puis surtout ce
qu'il faut quand même bien voir dans
beaucoup de télégisations européennes ou
même au niveau international c'est que
souvent on fait des législations mais on
n'a pas encore techniquement en termes
d'innovation ne connaît pas encore
scientifiquement quel est le meilleur
énergétique par type de véhicule par
type de bien on a encore en train de le
rechercher donc on voit que on a cette
législation parce qu'on est les
impératifs de de lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique mais
techniquement cette bataille
technologique elle est en ce moment donc
c'est ça l'intérêt et c'est vrai que les
pays qui seront les premiers à la voix
seront les gagnants pendant les 20
prochaines années bon allez on comme
promis je voudrais quand même qu'on
fasse une petite pause dans le débat
vous l'avez commencé à l'évoquer mais
pour bien expliquer ce qui est le marché
carbone c'est quoi les les entreprises
les entreprises payent pour avoir le
droit de de polluer moi je dis ça la
façon la plus basique possible est-ce
que est-ce que c'est ça en fait oui
alors c'est pas toutes les entreprises
environ 11000 entreprises je crois en
Europe qui peuvent acheter des crédits
qui sont ces quotas carbone pour
compenser finalement leurs émissions
alors après peut-être que tant
économiste vous avez le plus le je me
tourne vers Anne-Sophie parce que moi je
suis moins experte de du détournement du
mécanique enfin des quotas carbone qui
est vraiment l'idée c'est on a des
entreprises qui sont électro intensives
ou fortement émissive et donc pour
compenser ses émissions bien elles
achètent des quota carbone et après on a
un prix qui est fixé et normalement
l'enjeu avec le mécanisme ajustement
carbone c'est de
d'augmenter progressivement le prix de
la tonne carbone puisque c'est aussi ça
qui va pouvoir rendre compétitif
certains investissements dans la des
carbonations
je pense que vous la fait très bien
rajouter quelque chose
c'est à dire que plus vous allez poli
vous plus devez acheter donc en effet
plus vous avez si c'est pour moins
pollué on est fait moi vous avez besoin
d'acheter donc vous vous économisez et
donc du coup votre investissement pour
moins pollué qui est qui a un coût
certain et bien vous allez l'amortir
plus facilement
alors il y a aussi une particularité
alors c'est pas complètement clair
aujourd'hui mais en ce qui concerne
toutes les entreprises européennes qui
exportent dans des pays hors de l'Union
Européenne donc ils sont pas soumis à ça
aujourd'hui en fait ne pas tirez pas
entre guillemets de
de ce mécanisme d'ajustement carbone aux
frontières ce qui veut dire que elle
pourrait avoir un avantage compétitif à
produire avec moins évidemment des
missions de CO2 et donc pouvoir en faire
bénéficier ou exporter à moindre coût
d'autres pays et il y a comme aussi un
autre point c'est que il y a quand même
un lien très fort entre les émissions de
carbone et d'un côté l'énergie qui a
utilisé alors évidemment si on utilise
le charbon c'est autre chose mais
de telle sorte que ça va aussi inciter
un certain d'entreprises à décarboner
donc réduire leur utilisation d'énergie
et donc potentiellement trouver des
solutions et exporter derrière ailleurs
que en Union Européenne et pas
uniquement j'ai une question technique
c'est comment ça se mesure mais surtout
comment ça se vérifie comment on sait
est-ce que c'est du déclaratif les
entreprises disent ben voilà j'aimais
tant ou est-ce que on va aller et non
est-ce qu'on comment on vérifie en
Europe mais comment on va les vérifier
en Chine qui a un sidérurgie chinois de
va nous dire ben oui moi je respecte ou
je suis en dessous de celle-ci je crois
il y a plusieurs jeux déjà il y a en des
canevas et notamment il y a ce qu'on
appelle le bilan carbone qui permet
d'avoir gros smile une idée de combien
en fonction d'électricité qui est
utilisée enfin la source d'énergie qui
est utilisée d'avoir une grosse maille
de piquement le quantité après alors
même si c'est un petit peu ce que je
disais auparavant mais ça le bilan
carbone les entreprises sont pas obligés
de le faire non mais à ce moment-là ce
qu'on peut très bien faire c'est dire
écouter on a calculé que par exemple
pour une tonne on voit que en général
vous utilisez du charbon pour le faire
une tonne grosse maille et ben ça va
faire autant d'émissions de CO2 parce
que on considère que vous utilisez du
charbon pour le faire ah très bien vous
utilisez pas que les charbons ok
prouvez-le nous que l'électricité
provient de telles types d'endroits et à
ce moment-là potentiellement on peut
réduire effectivement les émissions de
CO2 donc on peut le faire de cette
manière là on est en ayant assez haut il
faudrait prouver qu'on soit en dessous
en fait et donc ça veut dire qu'il y a
pas un organisme international qui dit
vous polluez tant et donc vous devez
payer tant de de de droit de côte à
carbone c'est ça
le marché carbone il y a quand même
quelque chose c'est réglementé mais par
contre ce qui est vrai à l'échelle des
entreprises c'est qu'aujourd'hui il y a
deux sujets qui se posent c'est un la
méthodologie qu'on emploie pour calculer
son bilan carbone il y a quand même
plusieurs méthodologies qui existent il
y a pas une méthodologie qui serait
reprise vous pouvez prendre trois
entreprises du même secteur on a même
filière elle peuvent faire elles vont
peut-être utiliser trois méthodologies
différentes et l'autre sujet c'est
l'accès des bases de données c'est à
dire qu'on a besoin aussi de base de
données pour dire si je fais je produis
tel produit on considère que c'est tant
des missions carbone pour avoir une
démarche qui soit vraiment solidifiée et
consolidée
si la série ce Chinois dit ben moi mon
électricité vient d'un barrage
hydroélectrique qui va le vérifier on va
envoyer des gens là-bas on va demander
oui c'est à dire qu'effectivement il
faut être capable de mettre en place un
audit et si imaginons que l'audit soit
soit on n'est pas la capacité de faire
l'audit on dit bah écoutez ce que quand
vous dites que ça vient de la barrage
hydroélectrique ben non vous n'êtes pas
capable de le trouver de manière
certifié et après il y a des organismes
ratificateurs comme Veritas ou d'autres
qui sont accapables de le faire après
mais vous avez raison potentiellement il
peut y avoir même entre guillemets
l’espionnage économique derrière pour
l'oignon européenne pour dire bah tiens
on a les moyens de savoir comment
effectivement vous produisez tel ou tel
type de produit alors là où ça se
complique encore j'espère que vous quand
vous tient là que vous nous suivez c'est
que il y a des des quotas gratuits je
vais on va essayer d'expliquer ça et en
s'appuyant sur un rapport de de l'ONG
WWF publié fin novembre qui nous dit 53%
des émissions des industries les plus
polluantes n'ont pas été soumises à un
prix du carbone entre 2013 et 2021 à
cause de leur quota gratuit on parle
d'entreprises en France alors
pourquoi Anne-Sophie je me tourne vers
vous c'est pas un piège pourquoi il y a
ces quotas gratuits c'était pour éviter
les délocalisations c'est ça si on
essaye de bien comprendre alors c'est
vrai que comme vous l'avez dit c'est
compliqué c'est assez ambitieux donc ça
va être l'idée d'avoir eu on va dire
c'est quoi gratuit c'est peut-être
toujours de créer des incitations un
petit peu en douceur en disant bah voilà
on va pas vous tomber dessus du jour au
lendemain en disant de payer tant et
donc bah oui toute l'activité va partir
comme par exemple ce qui se passe aux
États-Unis donc c'est vrai que pour
beaucoup de secteurs en plus qui pouvait
avoir des difficultés qui ont été
victimes de désindustriations etc qui
était donc sinistrées donc elle est pas
beaucoup de capacités d'investissement
l'idée c'était de dire bah en gros on
vous donne du temps
le problème c'est que bien sûr
quand on donne du temps etc on crée
moins d'incitations et donc bah ça peut
créer un retard dans forcément la
transition et donc le fait moins pollu
lui donc c'est vrai que l'idée c'est de
se dire c'est bien de faire ça mais
peut-être que tous ces quotas gratuits
faudrait les revoir revoir les secteurs
peut-être les minimiser ou les donner à
des secteurs voilà qui sont plus
intensifs en investissement en tout cas
avoir une réflexion là-dessus pour pas
qu'il y ait un peu des passagers
clandestins c'est intéressant regardez
la réaction du président du syndicat de
l'industrie cimentière justement lui il
met l'accent sur ses côtés gratuits en
disant attention on en a besoin
aujourd'hui je peux y aller prudemment
parce que c'est quand même tout ça va
être effroyablement complexe et que ne
pas voilà ne pas enlever j'allais dire
ces quotas gratuits qui sont donnés aux
industriels avant qu'on soit sûr de
l'étanchéité du système
Dimitri Carbonel là on est vraiment au
cœur de la machine on comprend bien
qu'elle est complexe et que on n'a pas
encore tous les détails mais vous disiez
c'est 14 milliards c'est ça grosso modo
on annonce qu'on va récupérer c'est
cette somme grâce à l'attaque il faut
savoir à quoi on va l'utiliser donc ça
peut être ça ça peut être accompagner
des industries qui sont polluantes qui
bénéficiaient de quota gratuit à à
dépolluer à changer de logique à changer
de paramètre alors a priori il est prévu
que environ je crois 75% qui reviennent
au budget européen puis après et
derrière qui soit qui puisse être
redistribué donc aux États mais
effectivement il y a certainement des
systèmes de compensation mais encore une
fois qu'on pensait à Sion face ce sera
absurde que ça soit donné par exemple
industrie dans le domaine effectivement
de du ciment on utilise énormément de
enfin comment dire c'est très carboné
comme si par exemple on utilise d'autres
techniques pour développer je sais pas
l'utilisation de l'hydrogène ou d'autres
d'autres sujets et bien là effectivement
là c'est intéressant effectivement
d'accompagner l'entreprise d'une part en
termes d'investissement et peut-être
aussi entre temps pour qu'elle puisse
arriver au niveau après il faut avoir
est-ce que ça suffit ou pas et après
effectivement il faut voir aussi par
rapport à la concurrence qui va se
passer à l'extérieur de l'Union
européenne à quel rythme ils vont alors
est-ce qu'il y a un vrai risque de
désindustrialisation c'est ce que craint
le président de industrie qui était
citée dans Les Echos ce matin Alexandre
Sobo l'Europe fait le choix taxer le
carbone avec un risque de favoriser la
désindustrialisation espère pertinent au
moment où le tube bien choc énergétique
ou les États-Unis font le choix
subventionner massivement la
décarbonation de leur économie
Anne-Sophie alcif ce risque il existe
alors c'est c'est totalement le paradoxe
parce qu'on est on est en train de se
dire on en crée une taxé à bonnes pour
protéger nos entreprises et notamment
nos industries sauf que là on a les
représentants de cette industrie qui
nous disent attention danger en fait le
problème c'est que tout ça en effet par
une bonne intention des carbones etc
mais le problème c'est que notre
spécialisation en Europe c'est dans des
industries qui sont assez polluantes et
qui utilisent beaucoup d'énergie comme
vous le savez on n'est pas les premiers
dans la tech dans tout ce qui est
intelligence artificielle et autres qui
polluent en effet beaucoup moins fin
contre deux types de pollution mais qui
voilà on parle du ciment de la chimie
des industries qui se qui consomment de
l'énergie et donc c'est vrai que on est
spécialisé dedans donc la question c'est
très bien ça peut être actif pour
l'hydrogène pour les nouveaux secteurs
et ça c'est bien c'est secteur
stratégiques ont été mis en place mais
on a quand même aussi toute une
industrie qui est importante nécessaire
même en termes d'emploi en termes de
souveraineté on en a beaucoup parlé
pendant le covid la métal d'origine la
chimie le ciment qu'il a en effet sont
très carbonés donc là aussi aussi un
choix et ça qui est compliqué politique
aussi derrière ça veut dire très bien il
y a un risque des industrialisations
mais surtout même si on réindustrialise
quel type d'industrie on veut ça aussi
c'est une question et c'est vrai que
là-dessus il y a souvent très très peu
de réponses et c'est vrai que ces
industries là qui sont très énergivores
et bien se trouve en effet défavorisés
je suis pas d'accord avec ça c'est à
dire enfin je passais pas que je suis
pas d'accord dans l'absolu c'est on peut
pas dire on choisit les industries les
moins polluantes et on Fourg ce qui
pollue aux autres à un moment faut
assumer notre responsabilité
environnementale on a besoin de ces
industries parce qu'elles sont
nécessaires pour notre souveraineté et
on ne peut pas dire je veux bien
produire ça parce que ça pollue mal ça
pollue peu mais je ne veux pas de ça je
au reste du monde et je le réimporte non
continue à faire on se dit
responsabilise si un autre
responsabilité c'est un moment on
réindustrialise on se pose la question
non pas de ce qu'on veut
réindustrialiser mais comment
réindustrialisent et le modèle
économique de ces industries et on a des
vrais évolutions ont des carbone on a
tout une recherche sur l'innovation
indécarnation etc et si on se dit que
quelque chose n'est pas pertinent d'un
point de vue environnemental si on se
pose vraiment la question d'un point de
vue sociétal et bien à ce moment là je
crois qu'il faut aussi arrêter
d'importer ces produits on ne sait pas
les produire de manière verte sur le
territoire européen alors nous ne les
importons pas et l'autre chose c'est que
l'arrière industrialisation par rapport
au mix énergétique français par rapport
à nos normes sociales et
environnementales françaises et
européenne on restera quand même mieux
disons que les autres c'est il y a une
forme d'hypocrisie à se dire c'est bien
mais pas dans mon jardin c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment ce concept là parce que
c'était pas du tout ce que je le propos
mais un moment il faut aussi voir les
chiffres également aussi en termes
d'emploi et en termes de de coûts donc
c'est vrai que c'est très bien de dire
ça mais dans les faits en effet en
Europe on est spécialisé dans des
industries qui sont très polluantes et
ce que je dis c'est qu'il ne faudrait
pas qu'ils ne distorsion pour ces
industries là par rapport aux autres
c'est pas pour ça qu'il faut pas que ces
industries passent au vert il y a même
sujet
les États-Unis comme les États-Unis
cette bascule parce que là on nous dit 3
ans avant que ça rentre pour finir je
suis levé la question aussi c'est si
quel secteur on choisit de
réindustrialiser et quelle industrie on
décide d'avoir en Europe cette question
des choix de l'industrie si on se pose
la question que comment à mon sens c'est
une mauvaise question le choix c'est
très important pourquoi parce que vous
avez plein de secteurs vous avez déjà
des leaders vous avez déjà des pays qui
sont dessus donc se dire sur ces
secteurs d'avenir où on se positionne à
mon sens c'est essentiel parce que les
investissements sont colossaux donc le
but c'est pas de refaire des masques et
d'être numéro 1 dans toutes les
industries du monde non pas du tout à
mon sens c'est pas du tout ce qu'il faut
faire dans les gens qui pour la
réindustrialisation il y en a très peu
regardez même dernier rapport on disait
il fallait fabriquer des masques il y en
a qui le disent donc la question c'est
quel secteur stratégique et ce n'est pas
réindustrialisé donc est-ce que l'Europe
dans sa compliquité est capable de faire
ses choix après c'est aussi une question
de prise pardon mais avec plaisir c'est
ce qu'on regarde un prisme économique
est-ce qu'on regarde un prisme
géopolitique on peut prendre l'exemple
des semi-conducteurs il y a eu pendant
très longtemps se disait mais il y a une
concentration des semis conducteurs sur
Taïwan et on abandonne un peu cette
industrie on a un retour de cette
industrie et de volonté de reproduire
Issa en Europe aux États-Unis ailleurs
pour des questions de souveraineté et en
fait la question de la criticité si on
regarde un enjeu économique un enjeu
environnemental ou un enjeu aux
politiques et ben je vais pas mettre les
mêmes critères et c'est pour ça que
d'ailleurs on n'arrive pas à établir
aujourd'hui une liste sur quels sont les
actifs stratégiques à rapatrier en
priorité en France ou en Europe et
d'ailleurs on a quand même un marché à
27 qui nous permet aussi d'avoir avec
des spéci situation différente qui nous
permet aussi de jouer de jouer là-dessus
question pour vous Dimitri Carbonel
parce que vous l'avez évoqué rapidement
de ce philosophie sur le si on compare
ce que l'Europe est en train de mettre
en place on a bien compris c'est
compliqué on attend les détails c'est
plutôt novateur je pense que ça a jamais
été mis en place et puis à côté de ça il
y a les Américains qui proposent une
mesure qui est plus
simple peut-être plus clairement
protectionniste aussi quoi c'est des
crédits à nos à nos entreprises et on
peut même aller jusqu'à interdire
certains produits entrant si on les juge
trop polluant le plus efficace a
peut-être être le système américain non
alors un court terme sans doute à long
terme peut-être pas dans le sens où
parfois c'est ce que je dis c'est que
d'un côté les entreprises aujourd'hui
notamment sur le plan européen ou en
train d'apprendre à faire du 110 mètres
alors qu'auparavant il faisait du 100
mètres et peut-être aux États-Unis ils
sont en train d'apprendre à faire du 80
mètres directs sauf que avec
l'augmentation du prix l'énergie qui va
aussi toucher soit la Chine ou les
États-Unis avec la problématique au
niveau des matières premières les
entreprises seront de plus en plus face
à des 110 mètres 120 mètres haies avec
des haies qui seront de plus en plus
hautes donc l'Europe sera préparée c'est
ça la famille plutôt c'est exactement
même si on va souffrir pendant quelques
années on va souffrir pendant quelques
années et avec le risque de perdre des
marchés aussi vous voyez ce que je veux
dire
que je pense que l'Europe est en avance
ça fait mal soyons clairs on va se ton
attribuer de temps en temps sur un
serpent de sujets mais
en revanche on anticipe beaucoup plus
par cette démarche là et nous
entreprises seront beaucoup plus fortes
lorsque là parce que s'il y a une crise
énergétique comment on vit effectivement
en Europe aux États-Unis ou en Chine ça
va faire quand même nettement plus mal
parce qu'ils ont tellement l'habitude
que tout leur Soi donné avec l'inflation
by Act notamment que ça va être
catastrophique mais Anne-Sophie aussi
pourquoi pourquoi on met pas en place un
système tout simplement protectionniste
à l'américaine quoi je pense qu'on
complique la vie pose des questions
basiques mais j'assume alors ça en effet
c'est des choix politiques plus plus
économique moi c'est alors peut-être pas
la même chose que les États-Unis parce
que là c'est vrai que c'est très
offensif et c'est politique sont surtout
enfin l'adversaire c'est quand même la
Chine alors nous aussi on prend mais bon
c'est quand même le but de ça c'est
quand même pour répondre à la Chine qui
a mis en place ces mesures bien avant
les États-Unis donc là il y a vraiment
une prise on compte de ça par rapport à
ce que vous dites sur les États-Unis
attention ils sont tous suffisants
depuis deux ans ils ont pas la guerre
ils ont aucun problème d'énergie et eux
leur but c'est d'avoir les mêmes
voitures aussi énormes et qui consomment
autant sauf qu'elles soient électriques
donc on n'est pas du tout dans ces
pays-là oui mais ça c'est votre vision
européen il faut aussi écouter ce que
font les autres c'est toujours ça le
problème on peut être tout seul et dire
qu'on a raison mais il faut que les
autres soient aussi d'accord et
aujourd'hui dans la transition telle que
eux la voix surtout dans l'industrie
automobile c'est ça donc on va pas le
nier c'est juste l'effet et quand vous
regardez ça et bien en effet nous en
Europe c'est très bien d'être très
novateur en effet un moyen long terme si
ça permet des carboniser on se rend en
avance sur beaucoup de technologie on va
parler et là on peut récupérer des
marchés mais l'autre élément on en parle
beaucoup c'est la régionalisation l'idée
aussi c'est de privilégier le marché qui
est régional et ses voisins donc la
Chine ça va être de commercer comme ils
font des traités commerciaux avec au
Japon la Corée du Sud l'Australie
l'Europe finalement c'est après il y a
de plus en plus de protectionnistes tant
pis et les États-Unis ils ont leur zone
maintenant ils importent du gaz du
pétrole du Canada du Mexique plus du
risque de Russie d’arabie Saoudite donc
c'est pour ça qu'à mon sens le côté
stratégique et essentiel dans ces
politiques là et on peut pas mettre
juste l'inflation d'un côté l'écologie à
mon sens la chose la plus importante
c'est l'aspect stratégique et des
secteurs stratégiques et c'est vrai que
les deux autres grands blocs sont dans
cette logique là
pour compléter c'est pourquoi on
n'arrive pas à s'entendre à 20 pourquoi
l'Europe ne fait pas la même chose tout
simplement parce qu'on est 27 les
États-Unis c'est un pays et à 27 on a
des visions quand même très différentes
et je des situations économiques très
différentes je pense quand on regarde la
balance commerciale l'Allemagne avec
e-commerce l'Allemagne ou les Pays-Bas
ils sont pas dans la même situation que
la France et donc
protectionniste
qui était aussi porter par la France on
a on a un côté un peu peut-être vu qui
peut être vu un peu comme
protectionniste en France parce que on a
une situation industrielle qui n'est pas
du tout la même que nos voisins
européens et le pays le plus
désindustrialisés on a la balance la
plus la commerciale la plus déficitaire
d'Europe
la question du prix de l'énergie mais
enfin quand on fait moins 100%
les parts de marché ont évolué depuis 20
ans déjà il faut le rappeler parce qu'on
est toujours en train de se battre mais
le marché européen est très intégré
c'est à dire que le premier partenaire
commercial de l'Allemagne c'est l'Union
européenne c'est pas la Chine c'est pas
les États-Unis c'est après donc ça il
faut être bien clair et c'est le cas
aussi pour l'Italie c'est le caca
allemand de pour la France la France est
des intrusé comme le Royaume-Uni il y a
pas que la France qui a eu cette période
d'ici là et l'Italie c'était pas les
mêmes stratégies la Royaume-Uni a misé
sur une économie de service et il envoie
le retrait le résultat mais la France
est dans un hybride c'est on a pas une
place financière on n'a pas une
justement pour vous pensez comme ça aux
États-Unis vous avez des États qui sont
beaucoup moins industrialisés c'est vrai
que l'Europe a plus de difficultés à
penser de la fin parce que se mettre
d'accord que vous avez certains pays qui
ont justement cette logique là de faire
cavalier seul et d'avoir une vision
industrielle et de protéger leur
industrie il faut savoir que des juste
pour finir sur la Chine ou le NC etc dès
que vous avez des attaques importantes
parce que la première commerciale on est
dedans et aujourd'hui ce qui se passe
aux États-Unis c'est surtout l'industrie
allemande qui va prendre comme vous
l'avez dit dans des industrialisés donc
eux vont prendre beaucoup plus que nous
donc à ce moment là quand avec les
mesures protectionnistes américaines
donc quand ces mesures et elles vont
arrêter de d'augmenter les Allemands
tout d'un coup redeviennent pro-européen
et savent que de toute façon leur
premier partenaire commerciaux c'est
l'Europe alors si on revient à
l'objectif Dimitri carbonate de cette de
cette taxe carbone aux frontières
européennes vous l'avez dit l'Europe
c'est quand même un marché gigantesque
si on se place du côté d'un pays ou
d'une d'une grande entreprise polluante
à l'étranger
l'idée c'est quoi c'est de l'inciter à
faire des efforts à dépolluer sa
production pour garder l'accès au marché
européen est-ce que c'est effectivement
elle paiera plus de justement le parapa
de quota carbone donc ce qu'on est tout
à l'heure donc il aura tout intérêt à le
faire et alors là c'est peut-être
évidemment l'autre avantage c'est que
potentiellement il pourrait
en fonction effectivement le mode de
production aussi le vendre ailleurs
quand l'Union européenne il y a
peut-être potentiellement après il y a
quand un point au niveau de la
production c'est que lorsqu'on a un
outil de production on a tendance à le
garder le même pour l'ensemble pour le
monde entier donc ce qui signifie quand
même que ça peut effectivement engranger
une sorte de cercle vertueux
mais il y a un autre point c'est qu'on a
dit c'est la régionalisation va faire
que de toutes les manières on va avoir
de plus en plus tendance à prendre
effectivement des chaussons autour de
nous et que si les enjeux géopolitiques
se tendent on a tout intérêt à faciliter
la l'intégration de enfin de production
en interne et les entreprises on sont au
courant de ça on l'a vu à travers le
covid mais on le voit au plein d'autres
sujets il y a des entreprises
européennes qui par exemple travaille
déjà on parlait d'innovation tout à
l'heure produire un acide décarboné je
vais pas rentrer dans le détail parce
que c'est compliqué mais bon je il nous
reste à peu près 5 minutes qu'on parle
de l'hydrogène parce que moi j'ai été
d'abord surpris de voir que l'hydrogène
avait été rajouté à la liste des des
secteurs concernés je rappelle acier
ciment en aluminium électricité
hydrogène je sais pas qui veut répondre
à cette question mais
là aussi l'objectif c'est quoi c'est de
booster la filière de l'hydrogène vert
parce que c'est une c'est un objectif
européen c'est ça comme rapidement
l'hydrogène on peut le produire à
travers à partir de méthane donc ce qui
est émetteur fortement de CO2 on peut
aussi faire donc l'électrolyse donc on
utilise l'électricité mais si
l'électricité vient d'usine à charbon ou
d'usine à gaz vous avez votre hydrogène
toujours enfin il est pas vert quoi et
donc
l'enjeu c'est aussi d'avoir une filière
d'hydrogène vert mais qui provient
d'énergie soit alors pour être d'énergie
renouvelable même si ça pourrait être
tout à fait honnête c'est quand même
compliqué parce qu'on va avoir besoin de
beaucoup d'énergie ou de nucléaire
potentiellement c'est aussi ça l'enjeu
c'est vraiment d'avoir une filière qui
est
décarbonée de bout en bout donc si on a
si l'Europe dit on intègre l'hydrogène à
cette liste c'est pour protéger ou
accélérer le développement de cette
filière d'hydrogène verte vous parliez
de stratégie tout à l'heure là on est
dans la stratégie
alors on voit sur tout ce qui est poids
lourd véhicule vraiment important camion
là il y a il y a beaucoup de choses qui
ont été faits sur l'hydrogène mais c'est
vrai que sinon il y a encore beaucoup
d'interrogations sur quel mixte aux
États-Unis il y a d’hydrogène mais en
effet le coût de production et là aussi
beaucoup plus faible donc l'idée c'est
un booster et puis de voilà essayer de
rester peut-être compétitif par rapport
aux États-Unis essayez il y a une
dernière idée parce que on est passé sur
l'engrais mais moi je pense de mon de
mon fauteuil là de nom spécialiste je
dis engrais je pense aux agriculteurs et
j'imagine des agriculteurs qui nous
regardent disent mais attendez c'est moi
de toute façon je peux pas m'en passer
d'engrais donc je vais le payer plus
cher avec cette taxe carbone qu'est-ce
qui va se passer pour ce secteur là
c'est une très bonne question alors je
pense que le l'enjeu ça va être
d'encourager la production déjà il y a
des productions en Europe d'anglais
parce qu'on s'imagine toujours l'engrais
peut aussi dire que l'engrais les
émissions de GES c'est du Galaxy
bien que j'étais parti et pas du CO2
comme on le voit sur beaucoup de ces
industries donc encourager le
développement des filières
européennes et aussi travailler sur des
alternatives aux engrais
de ce type là
on les a pas forcément les alternatives
l'accélération de la décarbonation d'où
les financements de l'accélération de
l'innovation sur ces sujets là et c'est
parfois on se dit c'est quand on a une
contrainte qu'on met un coup
d'accélérateur puisqu'on voit le mur qui
qui arrive et trois les agriculteurs
vont être autant concernés que les
autres secteurs en fait c'est la
problématique elle va pas se poser plus
pour les engrais que pour l'acier ou
finalement peut-être que les moins
touchés entre guillemets c'est le une
partie du ciment puisque normalement
vous prod c'est plutôt le ciment
certains types de ciment pas tous à
proximité des lieux d'utilisation après
il y a des décimaux qu'on importe etc il
y a plein de vous pensez qui nous faudra
qu'on vient de temps pour juger de
l'efficacité de cette mesure
je termine ce débat en disant mais bon
ok on est pas sûr si on se dit cette
historique on est les pionniers mais
dans combien d'années on pourra dire ça
aurait été une bonne idée est-ce que ça
prendra plus de temps que prévu mais je
pense quand même que la démarche parce
que aujourd'hui déjà dès 2023 les
entreprises doivent évaluer l'impact
pètement carbone de leurs importations
on met trois ans c'est à la fois court
et ça foi long ils sont je pense que
l'Union européenne est en train de tâter
un peu le terrain voir ce qui marche ce
qui marche pas je pense c'est une grosse
expérimentations entre guillemets qui
est en train de se passer il y aura des
ajustements par la suite et je pense que
ça c'est positif ils expérimentent
quelque chose ils savent pas trop où ça
va aller pour l'instant bon ils ont une
grosse idée mais il y a plein de petits
détails ou des trucs qui vont aller des
trucs qui vont pas aller et je pense que
cette expérience
un impact mais l'essentiel on a trois
ans pour le voir Anne-Sophie oui je
pense que c'est pas voilà il faut pas
chercher un temps pour évaluer c'est
c'est pas du tout le propos de toute
façon c'est beaucoup trop tôt et à mon
sens notamment en termes d'incitation
des carbonisations ça on le verra quand
même plus rapidement parce que c'est le
message que ça renvoie exactement ça on
le verra par contre après en terme de
réindustrialisation est vraiment
d'objectif de réindustrialiser de
l'industrie européenne ça à mon sens ça
prendra des beaucoup beaucoup de temps
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat Dimitri Carbonel je
rappelle le titre de votre livre 2050
crash ou Renaissance qui est publié aux
éditions
librinova voilà merci encore